on average over 800 000 people kill
themselves every year around the world
suicide is the 15th leading cause of
mortality accounting for some 1.5
percent of all deaths more people die by
Suicide than are collectively murdered
die in traffic accidents or were killed
by animals it remains entirely strange
then that through the media we should
hear so much about killers and so little
about those who take their own lives and
judged by the statistical risks we have
far more to fear from embarking On A
Love Affair which may lead to the
suicide of one of the parties if things
go wrong than we do from sharks
according to the data from the oecd club
of developed Nations the causes of
suicide breakdown as follows 45 are
estimated to be physiologically based to
do with imbalances in brain chemistry
but the other 55 percent are judged to
be psychologically based with people
taking their lives because of grief
about romantic love Financial or career
failure humiliation shame status and
disgrace loss of Hope and Direction and
despair other
suicide is the Supreme reminder of our
intense psychological vulnerability and
of the deep difficulties we have in
communicating this vulnerability to
others and so of creating communities
imbued with the right life-saving sort
of attitudes governments in the wealthy
Nations tend overwhelmingly to direct
their efforts to dealing with poverty
illness and aging suicide alerts us to a
stranger problem we have the scale of
our psychological torment the extent of
the fragilities of our minds which
cannot necessarily be fixed by more
money or consumer goods from the causes
of suicide we learn how intensely we
need love self-acceptance meaning hope
status pride and forgiveness
these seven qualities are no luxuries
they can save lives
it's literature that has perhaps more
than any other medium alerted us to how
much these qualities matter in 1856 in
Gustav flabberg's novel Madame Bovary a
young mother commits suicide with
arsenic because she's been shamed by her
community because of her romantic and
financial transgressions
we learn from this that to survive we
need respect and forgiveness in 1599 in
William Shakespeare's Hamlet Ophelia
chooses to die rather than live without
a beloved Hamlet we learn from this that
to survive we need love and mechanisms
for coping with its loss in 1877 in Leo
tolsto's Anna Karenina the hero 11
contemplates suicide keeping a rope in
his office because he's lost any sense
of meaning and direction from this we
learned that to survive we need purpose
and significance
what makes many suicides so bewildering
is the element of surprise we may have
known that a certain person had troubles
we didn't imagine them on that scale but
surprise is evidence of an unwitting
neglect of one another and of ourselves
we're reluctant to Accord our
psychological needs the centrality they
deserve here is the philosopher Arthur
schopenhauer considering the matter in
1818 we should always be mindful of the
fact that no man is ever very far from
the state in which he would readily want
to seize a sword or poison in order to
bring his existence to an end
is telling that some countries have
higher rates of suicide than others in
Kuwait the rate is close to zero or 0.1
per hundred thousand people whereas in
India and France it's closer to 10 in
Japan it's distinctly higher at 17.9 and
China has the highest rate of all at
25.6
the numbers suggest that while no
Society can eliminate grief there is
much to do around the interpretation and
acceptance of difficulty which can
lessen the risks of suicide societies
with low suicide rates have a greater
acceptance of failure a higher role for
forgiveness and a status system that
honors intrinsic value over achievement
suicide is the greatest symbol we have
of the shared difficulty of Being Human
that its existence continues to surprise
us is a sign that there are much greater
levels of distress at large than we're
normally ready to countenance
still only a tiny proportion of a
population do ever commit suicide but
that some do so is evidence of the scale
of hidden anguish it's a proof of how
very fragile we all are and therefore
how we owe each other and ourselves so
much more compassion than we currently
tend to give